welcome to book TV's afterwards Allen
Beatty eminent journalists and
economists and historian as well has
written a fascinating book sort of
covering everything from ancient Egypt
to the Curtin times and in the economic
trends that have prevailed and have
taken hold and I think he finds quite a
few things that are common with today
and and ancient Egypt and even ancient
Rome and it's a fascinating book the
title of the book false economy that's
the part that actually kind of puzzles
me the most and I thought I would just
ask you why why did you write the book
and what is the meaning of the title
well the meaning of the title and the
title is often with books is pretty much
the last thing we came up with was
because I think there were lots of false
ideas that go around about the economy
and a lot of false ideas that have gone
around about human history the most
prominent one being that things that
were going to happen are always
inevitable that we are where we are and
there's nothing really very much we can
do about it some countries of which some
countries are poor and that's just the
way things are some countries were
always destined to be rich in some
countries always destined to be poor and
I kind of regard that as a fast economy
of thought and I think it's one of the
problems when you're just trying to
explain where things are at the moment
to say well let's look back into history
let's explain why we've got things are
and then okay that was it there's
nothing that anyone could have done
about it anyway along so really what I
was trying to challenge is the idea that
economic history is destiny or economic
history is fate and that we can't
control
we couldn't have control the past in
that we can't control the future well
you do an excellent job with that I
think making very clear what is kind of
baked in the cake and that we have to we
are given when we start out but also
what kind of choices were made and those
who make the good choices and those who
make the bad choices
his first chapter I think is one of
particular interest to Americans because
it sort of asks a question that I think
probably has occurred to a lot of people
in this country why did we turn out so
different from South America and you
the example of Argentina essentially the
two continents were discovered at rot
roughly the same time and they had the
same blank sheet a blank page to be
written on by the Europeans who came the
United States has fertile land arable
land and and wonderful resources but so
did Argentina and Brazil and so on and
so you discuss how why it is that
Argentina ended up being still part of
the poor developing world today whereas
the United States became the biggest
richest economy on earth can you kind of
go through that and how how all of that
happened starting with the from the very
beginning sure and in some ways it's
even more dramatic than that it's not
just Argentina was always poor and
stayed poor but that Argentina became
rich and that between the wars Argentina
is one of the ten richest economies on
earth and then it fell this as as the
old saying goes it's just about the only
economy that's ever managed to get from
the third world to the first and then
back again
so the question is why did it do that
well from the beginning the way in which
Argentina developed and the way in which
it settled its frontier was very
different from the US as you say both of
them have a similar they have these big
fertile grasslands you know the pampas
and the very but the US did it in a kind
of quite entrepreneurial way the
parceled out land to to small amounts of
land to entrepreneurial farmers who
really wanted to make a go of it and
increase productivity Argentina possibly
because of the legacy of being part of
the Spanish Empire essentially recreated
a kind of European landowning
aristocracy in the new world they pass
about huge waves of land often fairly
arbitrarily often to military officers
who done the conquering but they didn't
necessarily want to farm it they weren't
that interested in farming it or doing
anything kind of innovative with it all
they really did was was to encircle huge
sways of it with barbed wire and turn it
over to pasture and so that was kind of
one of the early missteps that Argentina
didn't from then on Argentina began to
be kind of run by a fairly small kind of
oligarchy along land owning all agog
they weren't very interested in
industrializing they weren't very
interested in saving their own money and
investing it in industry and while the
US had this sort of go ahead
entrepreneurial and classic save their
own money certainly they borrowed it
from abroad and they they imported you
know technology and know-how from
Britain and elsewhere but they were very
interested in whatever the the newest
thing was and industrializing an
Argentine really wasn't and that was the
first kind of initial misstep I think
that put Argentine on a different path
to the US and then for a while that was
kind of masked the the big differences
between the two weren't that obvious
because Argentina was just doing so well
pumping out food exports you know the
wheat and the beef and so forth but all
it really was was a glorified export
zone it wasn't really a kind of you know
stand-alone economy on its own
the Brits poured money in tech and
expertise into Argentina but all they
really wanted to do was just get out the
wheat and get out the beef they didn't
really want to kind of build the country
up and then when the Great Depression
hit that affected Argentina enormously
because of course it was agricultural
trade that was one of the biggest things
to be hit one of the biggest casualties
of the Great Depression and then where
the US kind of renewed itself and
democracy was tested but survived and
the federal government changed some of
the things it did and so forth Argentina
of what she slid into dictatorship and
it slid also into isolationism and that
the you know the the idea that Argentina
came away with and the Great Depression
was entirely the wrong one it was
basically we relied on the rest of the
world the rest of the world let us down
we're not going to do that and more what
we're going to do is build ourselves up
behind tariff forms we're going to cut
ourselves off we're going to be you know
isolationist and we're going to be
self-sufficient and that really was not
a recipe for becoming a rich country and
that's the moment at which some of the
early mistakes in Argentina made became
very obvious and Argentine began to
slide from the third one to the first
the first one back to the third yes that
is what's fascinating as I think a lot
of people don't even realize our gen
Tina was one at the top or ten one of
the top ten richest countries in the
world like a century ago
and lost its place because of some bad
decisions made during the I guess
primarily you're saying the Great
Depression was sort of the defining
event where the United States certainly
had trouble but ultimately over a very
troubled period made the right decisions
as far as adjustments in its economy
adjustments in the government and
regulation of the economy whereas
Argentina went to an extreme and was not
able to really pick itself up and and
succeed after that you know the way it
had started out and it's interesting as
you say also that the British played and
I think an equally important role in
both countries development providing
financing providing capital and
expertise but it was the Americans that
took took that and sort of ran with it
and mastered it themselves and and
became industrialized while the
Argentinians Antony ins were in a sense
resting on their laurels and just
staying an agricultural state primarily
so that's a fascinating chapter and I
guess helps to really define the
different the as you lay it out what
you're given what you start out with and
what you can make of it as a country
innocent as an economy I thought also
what your discussion of the Egyptians
and how they were at one time the
breadbasket of the world which i think
is also so i opening to a lot of people
the breadbasket of the ancient world of
course the the Romans at but then of
course today are unable to feed 80
million people because the population
has grown so much can you can you
explain all that and how that came to be
in sort of the significance of that for
a modern economy this is just
essentially a question or trade in that
during the ancient times because the
effective trading range for goods like
grain which were sort of kind of quite
bulky and low value and so forth
was the Mediterranean you know so within
the Mediterra
enjoying the Roman times Egypt had more
water than anyone else because they had
the Nile right and you know they had for
millennia had the Nile and they'd worked
out how to irrigate and how to and how
to deal with kind of irregular floods
and so forth and turn themselves into
into him you know quite a well-ordered
and stable society I mean the fact that
they could spare all the people to build
the pyramids and so forth and indeed
produce enough grain surplus to feed
ancient Rome as well was testament to
that and so at that point it made
absolute sense you know Egypt was better
at growing grain them pretty much than
anyone else within the Mediterranean but
then as technology changed and as we now
have shipping containers and you know
huge ocean-going vessels the effective
range of trade in grain is the entire
world it's not the Mediterranean anymore
and so Egypt might have more water than
anyone else in the Mediterranean but it
certainly doesn't have more water than
anyone else in the world
and once you've ought in countries like
the Ukraine Canada the US Australia
Argentina actually which have a lot of
water that that doesn't derive from the
Nile but falls from the sky in the form
of rain it's much more efficient for
them to to do to grow grain and for
Egypt to import grain it's a simple
question of comparative advantage and
but implicitly what's going on here is
really water
what Egypt looks like it's doing is
trading grain really what they're doing
is trading water
because if they really wanted to they
could just import you know hundreds and
hundreds of 40-foot containers of fresh
water and they could grow grain in the
desert themselves if they wanted to do
but that's not a very efficient way of
doing it a far more efficient way of
doing it is saying instead of importing
the water let's import things that are
made or grown with that with that water
so implicitly they're importing water
and this is a lovely idea that an
academic came up with a embedded water
or virtual water so he said and the
great thing about this is that it's
actually just the free market that does
it you don't need a treaty you don't
need any teams of international
bureaucrats you don't need world
government you just need the market all
you need to do is price water properly
so in countries where it's scarce it
should have a high price in countries
where it's less scarce it should have a
lower price and then let the market work
and so that's why Egypt was the
breadbasket of
world and is now the world's largest
importer of grain I mean the question
that I start that chapter is why does
Egypt import perfect staple food and the
answer I end up coming up with is you
know the question isn't really why is it
important half a staple food it's why
doesn't import more actually why why do
they actually still to this day use some
of the water some of the very scarce
water that's that comes down the Nile to
grow some of their own grain when in
fact would be much more efficient if
they used it for other things and then
continue to import grain so that's just
a way of kind of demonstrating theories
of comparative advantage and why
countries that have a lot of a
particular resource whether its water or
whether it's land or whether it's people
whatever should kind of specialize in
that and then trade with countries that
have that have more resources and
something else as fascinating although
the way you highlight how you can go
from being a country that has the the
water in the the land and the and the
resources to being the one that really
doesn't visa vie the rest of the world
and in in the long history of Egypt
they've gone had a complete reversal and
I'm sure other nations have are going
through the same kind of transitions the
issue of water is an interesting one I'd
like to dwell on because it seems like
that is getting to be and will be an
even more important issue as time goes
on as the world
the population grows and much of the
world's population seems to be in these
very dry areas there's talk of water
shortages how do you see that working
out I mean will they be able to import
their water through food and other
things and succeed or will we see any
kind of a crisis coming developing well
if the world trading system remains open
and free yes they should absolutely be
able to import it and this talk about
water and this cliche that the the wars
of the moment about oil but the next war
will be about water people have been
saying this for decades you know people
have been saying the Middle East will
have wars over water for decades and
there were conflict over wars over water
between Jordan and Israel and Syria you
know back in the 1960s and yet it
actually just hasn't happened
happened the Middle East there hasn't
been a water of water in the Middle East
and one of the reasons is that countries
have increasingly let this logic of
comparative advantage play out and they
have increasingly imported their their
water embedded in food no these
calculations that these academics have
done say that a lot of the countries in
the Middle East certainly Jordan which
is a kind of quite small dry country
cease to be able to become
self-sufficient in food decades ago I
mean if they had to grow all the food
that they just couldn't they don't have
the water to do it and yet they haven't
been particularly in water wars in
Jordan haven't particularly been water
riots in Jordan because they have been
able to import their food now one of the
difficult things about this is that this
relies on there always being food to
import and that it relies on there being
a global market in food and one of the
disturbing things that we saw over the
past couple of years with the food
crisis when the weather when the price
of food spiked is that it suddenly
looked like there wasn't going to be
enough food that I mean Egypt itself
banned exports of rice that grow some of
its own rice and the price of rice plate
30 percent in a single day and you know
to be fair to countries like this if
you're going to take the risk of saying
we'll import our food you need the food
always to be there to import and that's
one of the reasons I think that it's so
important to have international
organizations and organizations like the
World Trade Organization because they
kind of marry the importers and the
exporters and to the to those countries
which might have been inclined to say we
must grow our own food and must grow and
food no matter what if an organization
like the WTO can say to them look there
will always be food on the world market
for you to buy that gives them some
confidence and they're therefore able to
let comparative advantage clear out and
use their water for something else if
that food isn't there of course then
there's a problem and one of the really
unfortunate things I think we saw during
food crisis is that countries at the
same time they were desperately trying
to import as much food as possible you
know and cutting their their trade
barriers against food and so on just in
the show
at the same time in the longer term
we're saying we must now be
self-sufficient in food the lesson of
this is we can't rely on the world
markets and so you had countries like
the Philippines which is a very crowded
country you know not really a
particularly good place for it for a
great food and saying we want to be
self-sufficient in rice for two years
no I mean I've seen rice farms in
Philippines they're right up in the
mountains they won't cut into kind of
ice terraces in the mountains it's a
very inefficient and expensive way to
grow rice nonetheless they're so
obsessed with self-sufficiency and
they're so untrusting of the world
market that they say you know we'd
rather take that inefficiency we'd
rather pay a lot more for rice as long
as we can guarantee we can grow it
ourselves and that was one of the really
unfortunate outcomes I think of that
particular episode I was gonna ask you
how did you how would you evaluate that
it seems like did the World Trade
Organization or any of these
international organizations on you I
guess you have the World Food Program
played a very important role in
ameliorating that crisis for some of the
countries that were hit the hardest but
did the world rise to the occasion or
were there kind of as you say some
developments that look portend badly for
the future i one of the things as you I
get the impression that the crisis ended
mostly because of the collapse and
commodity prices that occurred when the
credit crisis set in and and the rest in
the world fell into recession the middle
of last year rather than as a result of
our concerted efforts through the World
Trade Organization or whatever to put to
prevent the crisis from worsening by
government action but what was your
evaluation did we make any progress
there were there's some warning signs
that we may have another food problem
and food crisis to deal with in the
future when the economy starts picking
up again yeah unfortunately not I agree
entirely with you I don't think any
focus has made at all I mean the World
Food Program and another kind of
humanitarian agencies whose role is
essentially just to do short-term famine
relief you know they did their best but
that role is not to design a long run
trading system
and one of the things I found really
remarkable having covered warm trade
talks for a number of years now is that
joint food crisis countries like the
Philippines and India and so forth at
the same time that they were cutting
their own immediate barriers to food
trade were arguing even more vociferous
lis that they should be allowed to raise
them again in the future and if and when
the world economy does recover I I think
there's a very good chance we will see
another food crisis three or five times
three of five years down the line
because I don't think there's those
lessons kind of we learnt at all I mean
one of the kind of wider points I make
in the book is that you know reform is
hard okay if it were for more easy then
I wouldn't need to write books like
that's right and you know the reason
that world governments haven't reformed
isn't just cuz they haven't read my book
yet it's because getting reformed and is
enormous ly difficult you're often
fighting against entrenched special
interests and you're in fighting against
ideologies and so forth but there are
certain times in which the form is much
easier than others and in particular
times of crisis okay and there is this
expression which I think I'd only heard
maybe you want until about a year ago
and now here in Washington I hear it
about every other day which is a crisis
is a terrible thing to waste
you know yes when crisis hits a lot of
things become possible that weren't
possible before I mean just going back
into history one of the one of the kind
of the greatest changes I think the
biggest shifts ever in policy to do with
to trade and food was in my own country
and Britain in the middle of the 19th
century when a set of laws called the
Corn Laws which were essentially a big
system of agricultural protection were
repealed and that was a really pivotal
shift when Britain said we're not going
to be an agricultural country anymore
we're going to be a manufacturing
country we're not going to hold up food
prices in order to benefit land owners
we're going to have cheap food because
that would mean lower costs for factory
workers and you know the form had been
coming for a long time but one of the
ways in which reform finally got through
was there was a gigantic food crisis
this is in fact exactly the same food
crisis that caused famine in Ireland and
one of the
that you know Boston and in New York are
now largely Irish became large Airy
cities or the those there's Irish people
that survived that dreadful famine often
emigrated but it was that it was that
kind of imperative in that disaster that
caused the government to say do you know
something
we now need cheap food we can't hold the
price of food up anymore we need to
become a country that permanently has a
policy of cheap food and it was
exploiting that crisis that caused them
to be able to repeal the Corn Laws and
as I say do one of the biggest changes
in trade policy the world has ever seen
and that was not to you they were seized
unfortunately the last couple of years
were the food crisis was an opportunity
I think this comprehensively mess Nazis
in fact it was quite notable that there
was almost there was no progress made in
the world trade talks on the very issue
of food and agriculture which has been
the sticking point for years now even in
the middle of this food crisis when it
would seem like it was obvious then we
need a more rat we needed a more in a
rational system of trade in food so I
can see why you think that not much has
been solved and in fact you did see some
on the the supplier side also you saw
some rather bad things happen like
Argentina starting to export its excuse
me toxics exports of food even though
it's a major provider of staple foods to
the rest of the world and yet during
this didn't during this crisis they
actually started taxing their food
exports absolutely I mean that it's 19
and doing this doing the same silly
things they've been doing for over a
century and in the middle of this I mean
in the middle of this crisis
you know Argentina and one of the great
beef growing nations of the world people
who are Inverness artists at the time
told me that in many cases there was
there was no beef in the supermarket
right they've filmed up the meat
counters and the supermarkets with pasta
because they'd imposed all these taxes
on exports and the farmers simply
reacted by going on strike and saying
we're not going to you know we're not
going to have our income stolen from us
and so at a time when Argentina should
have been benefiting enormous Lee
because the one
think that they were very good at doing
the price had gone up instead of which
production ground to a halt in the
country Union and the country was at
each other's throats
certainly we you have documented very
well how we're able to sort of blow the
opportunities that are given us that you
know by doing things like that so really
it's a very interesting history of the
trade around the world that you bring
about and the really in there the
influence that religion may or may not
have I think that a lot of people do
tend to think that religion plays an
important role somehow in our economy or
how we end up you've had this idea the
Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism that somehow are the
puritanical spirit that we have in the
United States is something that helped
us become a powerful industrialized
nation but then you really kind of back
that down quite a bit and you
acknowledge a role that the in the
religion plays and then and cultural
elements play generally in the economy
but that generally it's more a result of
the interplay of the power elites with
and how they use religion to solidify
their their control perhaps and so on
the going back to Argentina just for
simplicity I mean I think that a lot of
people have thought that the Catholic
Church has the influence of the Catholic
Church was an important factor that held
South America back versus the Protestant
ethic which is a more innovative
individualized work ethic and rewards
for effort and so on in the in the North
American sphere but you didn't find that
particularly to be the case did you I
don't think so no I mean if you look at
what the you know if you look at what
the thinking of Puritan theologians
actually was and indeed even once they
pitched up in North America the thinking
of the Massachusetts colony you know
they had a whole bunch of restrictions
on private enterprise which would you
know struggle to make it into the
Harvard Business School
they often invade against the the the
false idea is somebody said at the time
that the commodity is is worth as much
as somebody will pay for it you know the
early colonists set limits on interest
rates they set limits on prices they
disapproved with profiteering and in
many cases they wanted to live actually
kind of quite an ascetic you know non
material life away from away from the
profit motive and away from that the
desire to to to gain wealth I mean I
take I think probably a kind of more
power centered if you like a more
materialist kind of view of the role of
religion which is that if you look at
individual religions and if you look at
the kind of theology of individual
religions it's really hard to trace
through any link from that to the
societies that actually believe in them
everyone believes that there is
prohibition on lending money at interest
in the Koran for example which is why I
focused at that particular chapter on
Islam and that's not really true I mean
it's not to ended theology and it's
certainly not true in the practice at
the time indeed if anything there's a
stronger prohibition on money lending
within Christianity than there is within
Islam and I think really what matters
with religion is not what the particular
theology says but just the rome that
that religion can play in any given
society what I would say was
instrumental in turning North America
into this thriving free thinking
capitalist individualistic society was
not really the fact that some of the
early colonists were Puritans but this
if you didn't like it you could go and
found a religion they even founded a
colony somewhere else you know you
didn't like the stifling conformity
Massachusetts right you can go and find
Rhode Island or you could go to found
Pennsylvania and one of the most
important things I think about the
Protestant Reformation within Europe it
wasn't that it succeeded and it wasn't
that if they owned is that it half
succeeded I think that was it the best
thing about it was that it half
succeeded
and so it created you know not a new
society run on entirely different lines
but it created this sense of plurality
that there were different decisions that
you could take through different routes
you could take there were different ways
of the truth there are different ways of
thinking about things and by challenging
that the primacy of any given one you
know religiously art Authority and one
religious theology it let people come up
with their own ideas and it also meant
that when merchants and traders and so
on and so forth began to grow as
organized groups they were able to have
you know inconvenient laws inconvenient
religious rooms and so on disposed of
without threatening the entire basis of
a society I think that's the most
important thing about the way that
religion works it's not what the
religion itself says it's the way that
it's used by authorities within any
given country thank you very much and
we'll continue this conversation in a
moment afterwards and several others
c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts more with Allen
Beatty and patrice hill in a moment
every weekend c-span 2 has 48 hours of
nonfiction books and authors on book TV
Sunday c-span 2 continues its live
coverage of the Los Angeles Times
Festival of Books with more authors
panel discussions and callin programs
later its afterwards Financial Times
world trade editor Alan Beattie
on why some countries are more
financially prosperous than others he's
interviewed by patrice hill chief
economic correspondent for The
Washington Times and Sunday May 3rd on
in-depth your calls for political
satirist and author Christopher Buckley
nonfiction books and authors every
weekend on c-span 2 for a complete
program schedule go to book TV org
afterwards with Alan Beatty and Patrice
Hill continues welcome again to book
TV's afterwards
Alan Beatty you reach some very
interesting and surprising and perhaps
amusing conclusions about the influence
of corruption on the world economy in
particular nations you look at China you
look at India you look at Tanzania you
look at Indonesia and you what the
surprising conclusion I found was that
he you found that corruption generally
is not a great thing for an economy but
in some some nations it works better
than others and there seems to be better
forms of corruption than then and so can
you just give us your your thoughts and
your ideas in this area yeah I knew this
one was going to get me into telling
even when I was writing it yeah I think
everyone knows corruption is a bad idea
and over the last 10 or 15 years or so
there's been a lot more interest in the
role of corruption and stopping poor
countries get rich know institutions
like the World Bank never used to be
able to talk about it at all and then
they've moved more into talking about it
but what I kind of found interesting is
you know almost all countries have been
corrupt at some point in their history
you know Britain was unbelievably
corrupt 18th century and English
politics was astonishingly corrupt
everyone everyone knew it was and whole
empires have been built by corrupt
colonial officials and so on so what I
wanted to try and do is say you know is
it something about particular kinds of
corruption or other bits of corruption
and the two countries are looks at it in
particular are Indonesia and Suharto
became persons in 1968 and Tanzania and
Julius Nyerere
now Sahara was famous for being corrupt
and he was also you know let me make no
bones about it
an unpleasant blood-stained murderous
dictator Julius Nyerere was a very
decent man
by all accounts very honest man and so
forth but the corruption in Indonesia
seemed to work a lot better simply
because it was so centralized
essentially it was just a form of tax
that Suharto controlled everything
himself
he knew everything that was going on in
the economy and he restrained the amount
of kickbacks that people were taking and
if you try to take too much you'd be
fired and a couple of kind of famous
occasions when people tried to exploit
too much the people around the docks for
example in Indonesia tried to take too
much and he summarily fired the woman
brought in a foreign company instead so
you allowed so much but no more and what
if corruption is centralized and
organized and predictable as I say it
essentially becomes a tax you know and
taxes don't necessarily stuff economy is
growing
whereas what happened with Tanzania and
near arey
was that although he wasn't corrupt
himself he created this enormous lis
complex system of state intervention in
the economy which created thousands and
thousands of opportunities for
lower-level officials to enrich
themselves and to be corrupt and he had
no means of controlling them whatsoever
and so the economy essentially ground to
a halt I mean actually went into reverse
not because he himself was a bad person
but because the way he ran the economy
encouraged this disorganized
decentralized kind of corruption and you
know there's a difference between the
sort of cream skimming corruption where
you take ten or fifteen percent off the
top but basically leave the economy to
run and the kind of corruption that film
TV game shows supermarket sweep you know
where you've got like a minute or two
minutes to run around supermarket just
clearing everything you can and and
taking everything that's not nailed down
and running off with it and I think
those are the differences between those
two particular forms of corruption and
it's why although corruption is not a
good thing in itself it can be much
worse in in one circumstance than
another yes and you mentioned if you
look at the two rising Asian Giants
China in India once again you can make a
distinction between the kind of
corruption that you a business might
encounter in each one China has been
quite the success and especially in the
manufacturing area and yet they do have
endemic corruption in their bureaucracy
in their government but apparently it's
a more efficient kind of corruption than
what you encounter in India where I
guess there's just a whole lot more
moving parts and confusion and so on can
you get into that a bit well that's the
thing I asked I mean the best
explanation I heard on this was from a
very senior official in the Indian
government I asked about it a few years
ago and said why is it they're trying to
get so much more fun in direct
investment than India does and he said
well find investors are scared out of
India because of corruption and I said
but what about China China's everyone
knows that China is corrupt any kind of
side event said yes the thing with China
is there's only one party to bribe you
only got to get one guy on a side then
you're fired
whereas India and Indian politics
particularly time has gone on actually
has splintered into this really kind of
quite dysfunctional system of hundreds
of small parties which are based on
regions or castes or particular
interested groups and so getting
anything done in any given area often
involves you know bribing the government
official in charge of it and the local
party and and the other party in the
governing coalition and then the party
who will expose the first lot if you
don't bribe them as well and so forth
and so it's not you know it's not that
they're corrupt or not corrupt it's just
some countries are streamlined that
corruption and some countries have
inefficient of course yes we can see one
of the points you make course technology
affects the world economy and our wealth
our potential for wealth quite a bit
we've seen that very much in the last
century how a technologies really affect
our economic like livelihood and one of
the points you make is about just it
seemed like an arcane point and yet it
seems so important in retrospect which
was the development of the container
standard container which is now used on
railroads ships the same sized
containers and how this really
revolutionized world trade I I gather
what you're saying is that if this was
developed around the early 70s era and
was adopted during that period and you
really saw an explosion in world trade
because of how much more efficiency you
had in just the loading
unloading the actual mechanics of
getting goods from one market to another
can you talk about that a bit yeah I
mean this is this is a story that's been
there's been told by by several authors
Andy you know the amounts of savings
that were possible were absolutely
astonishing I mean the kind of the
amount of drop by maybe a hundred fold
the cost of shifting things around that
around the world drop maybe 104 or to
100 because of the shipping container
but the thing I found interesting about
it is that you know in retrospect as you
see it just seems so blindingly obvious
but even once people have kind of
grasped the point of it it took a decade
or more actually to get this thing
adopted because the various shipping
companies had all come up with their own
versions of the shipping containers you
know the really critical thing is having
the same size everywhere in the world so
every shipping container every port is
all organized around having what is now
the eight foot by eight foot by twenty
foot or a 4x4 by 40-foot container and
that the the detail of this at the time
you know one of the big companies
involved they had a 35 foot container
because their big port was in New Jersey
and that was the biggest container you
allowed in New Jersey another one had I
think 24 foot container because their
main cargo was tinned pineapple candor
pineapple from Hawaii and that was
literally the biggest container that you
could film with its can pine about for
weather without it being too heavy there
is yet another company that only had a
17 foot container because they did lots
of business with Latin America and they
had to truck these things around kind of
winding mountain roads and so it took
years and years and years to bang all
these people's heads together and get
them to say we need one sized container
and in the end as often it was the
government that had to come in and do it
and it's also often actually in America
it was the government with the National
Security and Defense
rationale who came into doing it was the
Federal Maritime Board that handed out
and the federal subsidies for
shipbuilding and they said they just
said ok we're not going to hand out any
subsidies unless it is around this new
standard container size and that had the
effect of just like that
of getting if on to adopt the same size
so you know just because it just because
a technology comes up and just because
it seems so obvious and so much better
it doesn't mean it came to be adopted a
lot of the time you need to overcome
kind of intense interest and the way
things have already been done and Austin
it takes the government to do that
mm-hmm
it was it because the United States
adopted the standard and we are the
biggest importer I guess and maybe
what's still one of the biggest
exporters that that was that really a
critical that was one of the most
critical ways of doing it was also then
adopted by the US military itself and
then the Vietnam War and other things
like this actually one of the yeah a few
good things come out of Vietnam war was
the kind of spread of containerization
around the world so yes certainly the
u.s. played it quit it wasn't the only
thing but certainly the u.s. played a
critical role in that mmm-hmm well mr.
Beatty has a tremendous knowledge of the
whole history of the economy around the
world and I think we are in one of the
most difficult economic times in our
lifetime right now and interesting to
know how you two you would apply the
lessons of history what we've learned
what that works what doesn't work and
how you would apply it to our current
circumstances how are we doing as far as
our response to this deep financial
crisis and economic downturn I think
some countries are doing better than
others some countries have learnt the
lessons and some people within some
countries of doing better than others
just to start with with the bad things
first I think a lot of continental
European countries for example in
Germany really haven't grasped the
nature of the crisis that we're in I
think they still think we're fighting an
inflationary challenge such as that we
saw in the 1970s with the oil shock or
in Germany's case at the end of 1980s
with the reunification of Germany and
they still got this obsession with sound
money in keeping debt low and so forth
which I don't think is the right
response at all I think this is
essentially in 1930s type crisis and
that the real risk is deflation and what
countries should be doing is those that
can afford it should be pumping as much
stimulus into their economy as they can
and indeed intervening aggressively to
rescue the
the financial system and I think you saw
this recently with the with the group of
20 meeting you know when France and
Germany one of their main obsessions
seem to be to be going after offshore
tax centers and tax havens now you know
that may or may not be a good thing in
itself but I've not seen the convincing
explanation of how offshore tax centers
had a whole lot to do with the current
financial crisis and my my favorite
metaphor this was someone who's involved
in the g20 process that this is a bit
like a bar fight isn't it a bit like a
bar brawl you know you wait to the fight
breaks out then you take a swing at the
guy who always wanted to hit but whether
he had anything at all to do with
starting the fight is not the issue so I
don't think those countries have got it
particularly I think the u.s. is closer
to having got it and certainly the
current administration is closer to
having got it some elements of Congress
I'm not quite so sure about but the twin
approaches of pumping stimulus into the
economy and intervening aggressively to
sort out the financial system I
certainly think the response is better
than it was in the 1930s I mean I've
certainly think we've learned that I
haven't seen anyone suggesting we go
back to the gold standard I haven't seen
anyone seriously suggesting that we
should try to be balancing our budget at
this particular time if it will mean I
think we should if anything go even more
aggressively and I'd like to see more
aggressive intervention in the financial
system and it's not clear to me whether
or not the administration would like to
do that and they're being restrained by
Congress or whether they don't think
that kind of going in and taking over
banks home sale is a sensible thing to
do at the moment but certainly I think
this we've loved some of the lessons
back from the nineteen thirties and one
lesson we do seem to be have learnt or
I'm fairly optimistic about is actually
the issue of our protectionism because
you know you hear a lot about
protectionism and I write a lot about
protectionism but really even the
protectionist moves we've seen so far
which are worrying are nothing like the
kind of home sale receipt into isolation
that we saw in the 1930s and you know
some of the the laws and the rooms and
the systems that were put in after the
nineteen thirties the creation of the
general agreement on tariffs and trade
which then became the WTO I think have
have constrained us of making some of
the same
steaks that we made back then so you
know I give some countries better better
marks and others but in general I think
we've certainly shown quite a few of the
signs of having learned the lessons of
the past
you mentioned and everyone agrees that
dealing with the huge trillion-dollar
losses in the financial sector is the
key to weathering this crisis and
getting the economy back on its feet and
yet that has been the hardest part for
the United States and the quick the
stimulus bill passed almost like greased
lightning night and so fast that you
know if you blinked you missed it but we
are struggling to get in place a system
government intervention program to deal
with the the monumental losses at banks
it does seem to be primarily a political
problem and I don't know how this jives
with recent history some people point to
Japan and the problems that it had
dealing with its they called zombie
banks in Japan and a lot of it
apparently was because there was very
little public support for putting money
into these banks that's the fundamental
problem we have in the United States is
this an area we could really stumble and
hurt ourselves and reverse some of our
progress yes I think it's a real problem
I think there's a lot of legitimate
anger I mean lid and you know absolutely
you know accurate legitimate anger about
what certain banks and the financial
objective as a home has been doing but
the wrong lesson to draw from that is
we're not going to give them any money
at all we won't do anything to them at
all or we're going to do is try and
punish them because although that you
know that may be kind of comforting in
the short term and may deliver you know
political rewards in the short term I
think if it leads into the sense that we
will never put any more money into the
financial rescue that's that could be
kind of kind of quite a damaging thing
to do and I think you know anger is all
very well
anger is quite justified but I think the
accurate thing to do is to try and
channel that anger into having a
sensible
reform program now and actually try and
channel it further down the line into
ensuring that we have regulation that
means that this doesn't happen again
but allowing this this sort of pitchfork
rebellion attitude to to simply mean we
will never give another Center of public
money to warm state I think is it's
quite damaging yes it's a that's
certainly the very issue that we have
today in the United States another issue
that I think Americans worry about is
the huge debts that we have and so far
our response you know we we are the
largest debtor in the world now and we
are dependent on money coming in from
outside the United States to finance our
debts our national debt and our trade
deficits what part of a big part of our
response has been to go even deeper into
debt and that makes a lot of people feel
uneasy we are now having a budget
deficits of over a trillion dollars for
years to come are projected were running
at almost a two trillion dollar rate
right now these are just unheard of I
mean two trillion dollars is the size of
whole economies even in the developed
world and that's how much we're running
of a deficit this year and this is all
to finance our stimulus our banking
rescue program and and just generally
the recession are we in danger here of
making a historic mistake in running
short-term deficits no I don't think so
because I think the way to reduce
deficits in the longer term is to get
the economy going again you know if if I
were trying to bring America down what
I'll do at this point is say you should
do nothing you should just let the
financial system collapse and you know
the economy could be in recession for 10
or 15 years sure you don't have slightly
smaller deficits in the longer term but
you don't have bigger deficits in in the
shorter term but you have bigger
deficits in the longer term I think
these are precisely the times when
countries like the US should be running
deficits you know one of the reasons
that one of the things that you do in
building up policy credibility year
after year and decade after decade is
that when you have times like this you
can indeed run deficits the problem has
been that the US has been running
deficits in good times as well and I
think it's ironic that a lot of the
people currently complaining about you
know deficits in the short-term are the
same ones who voted for the tax cuts and
the spending increases that have been
building up kind of medium term deficits
even in even in good times so it's a
very difficult argument to make and I
can understand why people are worried
about debt but I think the most
important thing is do what has to be
done now in this time of extraordinary
crisis and at the same time
try and set in in place policies that
will return the budget towards balance
and will return the budget towards
medium term sustainability but you know
trying to try to do that by cutting back
on spending this year or next year I
think will end up costing more in the in
the long run mm-hmm now you mentioned
that at times of crisis in it you look
back at history going back a thousand or
more years that is when the decisions
are made often the definitive decisions
are made that that affect the course of
history in a country that effect whether
people will be rich or poor in the
future and particularly in the US we
have been successful at negotiating
crises in the past and making the
adjustments that were necessary you were
emphasizing how flexibility in the
willingness to adjust and make the
changes that are needed to weather the
crisis and to prevent it from happening
again what kind of adjustments are
needed today in the US and the world
economy generally to get through you've
mentioned what we need for them to get
through the crisis now but in the long
run how should our system change so as
to ensure there is no crisis like this
again and that we maintain prosperity in
the longer term I mean the financial
services sector needs to be returned to
its proper phone
which is providing finance for the rest
of the economy and in particular you
can't get into the situation where if
financial institutions are
simultaneously too big to fail and are
taking huge risks getting involved in
too risky getting involved in whiskey
assets that they can't that they don't
understand
and essentially hoping the or expecting
that the government will bail them out
so I'm not quite sure we need to go back
to the kind of the olden system of a
strict division between commercial
banking and Investment Banking but
certainly there needs to be a
recognition that you know banking has a
utility to to help the rest of the
economy is a different thing from people
taking bets on the way particular
financial assets will go which again it
is to some extent redoing some of what
was done in the nineteen thirties and
and possibly that we've moved too far
away from so that's one of the most
important things I think the other
important thing is putting the US public
finances on a sustainable path and one
of the things that happened throughout
the 1990s is that you know more and more
liabilities were added the liabilities
of Medicare were increased and nothing
was done to reform them nothing was done
on Social Security the reaction to every
problem seemed to be a tax cut and there
was just simply no sense of how this was
ever going to get back into it you know
balance in the medium term so I think
those two of the most important things
that the u.s. can kind of do by and of
itself
globally what needs to happen of course
is that the the world economy needs to
be rebalance you know the u.s. cannot
continue always being the consumer of
last resort and countries like China
can't continue always exporting their
way and generally if I can't always
continue exporting the way out of
problems so there needs to be a
rebalancing of global demand away from
the US and towards towards the service
countries like China and Germany well
that would seem to be the hard part in
the sense that how do you get people to
start spending in the middle of a big
recession or in the case of say China
big slowdown where they're losing jobs
as well as we are if if you're going to
rebalance
the economy that's essentially what has
to happen instead of depending on
American consumers to pull the world out
which may end up happening actually the
idea is to try to get the rest of the
world to sort of have more balanced
economies and our self is included going
back to savings one of the points you
make which is interesting historically
especially at this time is that at one
time the US was a creditor nation we did
save and we were the ones that helped
Europe pull itself up after the world
wars and help them and and that was
actually a key reason isn't it that we
came to be the world's big power in the
last century because we were in a
position to help like that so how did we
get to be from a creditor nation like
that to a debtor nation can you that's a
trend that I don't remember you touching
on in your book and I think that's a
that's an issue as you say one of the
big issues we have to address in the
future in the world and in the present
crisis what how do you get people to
change their saving habits and their
spending habits what needs to be done
here well part of the problem is that in
a sense certainly in in kind of recent
decades in a sense countries like China
would just kept shoveling money at the
u.s. you know they kept intervening
against their own currency and and
building up vast reserves with the with
mean with the deliberate aim of
affecting the value of their own
currency and encouraging their own
exports and you know there was at least
as much kind of push as pull as it as it
were and you know one of the reasons
that the u.s. stopped saving so much is
that essentially China was saving on its
behalf and then lending them the money
so what needs to be done is that needs
to be be balanced and that will be done
through a combination of you know US
households rebuilding their own balance
sheets and beginning to save more but it
will also be done by those countries
which are in surplus changing their
behavior you know it's it's both sides
have to act it's not just a question of
the country
have been running deficits that are the
ones to blame and actions need to be
taken in on both fronts and you were say
you know how are these other countries
going to do this consuming well yes and
you quite right it's hard to get their
consumers to consume that much of the
moment in which case it forms of the
government's to do it and that is
precisely why the the the Chinese and
the Germans should be pumping a lot of
stimulus into their own economy with
with the hope that you know one of the
things that that will do is help to
rebalance the world economy along the
way mm-hmm yeah that's a very good point
are we are we making I gather you're
saying we're not really making too much
progress in that area although it's not
the most the front burner item right now
but it's it's some ways it should be the
front burner item I think we're doing
better with some countries and others I
don't think we're doing particularly
well with Germany China you'll never
quite sure because you're never quite
sure how much of these announced Chinese
stimulus does actually exist or whether
it's double counting or triple counting
or something and I must say one thing
that the Chinese government certainly
seems to have learnt in its
conversations with Western governments
is how to spin spending announcements
and how to announce there's the the same
bit of spending two or three times yes
so how much of this actually
materializes will wincing well there's
an issue to what this current crisis
some people have a feeling China has
been an ascendance for some time quickly
rising to be the world's third largest
economy and certainly has the potential
to become to unseat the United States as
the world's largest economy could that
be one of the outcomes of their current
episode with the United States economy
now shrinking at a five or a percent
rate or more and China still growing at
more than five percent it could but I
mean China's economy has been so
dependent on export demand for so long
that in the sense they're not in a in an
enormous e strong position either I
always kind of think of China in the
u.s. is a bit like a kind of
dysfunctional marriage you know they
they kind of they exchange a lot of rude
words but they're kind of dependent on
each other as well and it is actually
hard I mean it's genuinely hard for an
economy like China which has spent so
long encouraging its export industries
and having
you know world class often find
investment driven export industries on
on the coast and and their entire
economy oriental a lot of the economy
oriented around that it kind of
difficult for them suddenly to shift
from that to being a domestic spending
economy you know these people can't kind
of instantly leave the factories and
become care workers or whatever else is
needed in in kind of inland China and so
you know China needs the US and China
needs us demand and the other issue
that's been talked about recently is
this issue of a new global currency a
new global reserve currency and so forth
you know this is something that the
Chinese themselves of her brought up but
China is in it again in this it's kind
of arguing from a position of weakness
or a position of dependence which is
they've built up these vast dollar
reserves themselves they're worried
about a form in the value of those
assets because that means they take a
big hit as well and it's something that
so you know a shift or reserve currency
could have painful consequences for them
as well so thank you very much so those
economies actually depend on each other
as much as they compete yes that's very
interesting that the the future of the
world currency as well as seems to be at
stake in this thank you so much Alan for
for your insights and very thoughtful
presentation in the world history of the
economy we thank you very much for
appearing on the show